hello how's everybody doing out there
welcome it is uh Bond as they say it's
excellent to be back here in Porto at
NDC PTO and uh I'm Dylan and I'm going
to talk to you about email for an hour
hour and you're all here so I'm assuming
that lots of you either think that's a
good idea or you're like I can't wait to
see what this guy's going to come out
with next and uh we're going to kind of
usurp the Trope of the conference talk
here we're not going to do the live demo
at the end we're going to do the live
demo right at the beginning and it is an
interactive live demo so what I'd like
all of you to do is get your phones out
okay that now this is very important you
are about to see a button that says do
not push this button
yet as Eli said in their talk this
morning if you put a sign up saying do
not dig here you know what human beings
do they get a spade and they say please
do not push the button yet that says do
not push the button yet because while
all of you are getting that lined up and
following the instructions on your
screens I'm going to switch over here to
our Live status page that's looking
pretty good and yes somebody can read
instructions somebody else can read
instructions what does it say on the web
page it says stand
up I mean this is a very good sign none
of those have changed color yet so the
brown one there that's somebody who's
using a fake
domain don't game the system or you get
me in trouble with the people who I pay
to send the emails for me the yellow one
there is somebody who's already pressed
the
button we don't know who you are but I
can find
out so we'll give it another moment or
so we'll give folks time to uh get
connected and uh get their address in
there and yeah some people are getting
very excited like I have to push the
button I can't not push the button don't
put an unpushed button in my line of
sight I must push it that looks to me
like a statistically valid sampling so
are we ready are you ready to push the
button three two one push the
button look at
that and when you push the button we're
going to send you an email so go and
check your email
and in the email there will be some
further
instructions and the ones that are
starting to go green there those are the
people who found that in their
inbox we may have a couple starting to
go pink any second if any of them go
pink it means that it's gone to your
junk mail now we got quite a few on
there that are still yellow we got quite
a few few people who are still standing
up and uh all you folks who are still on
your feet out there you're probably
thinking this is getting a little
uncomfortable everybody else is sitting
down where's my email now the world that
we live in it kind of runs on email
right email is important I went to open
Photoshop this morning and it said oh
yeah you need to confirm your identity
before you can run the software you paid
for we're sending you an email and the
expectation is that email is
instantaneous right now all you folks
who are still on your feet remember who
you are okay you can sit down now that's
fine we we'll get to that in a
second email we expect to be instant we
use it for all kinds of important things
you need to sign into Azure to fix a bug
in production oh yeah we just need to
check your identity we'll send you an
email and all you folks who were still
on your feet there you're thinking this
has gone wrong this is uncomfortable
this is like too long to have to wait
but this is RFC 5321 5321 October 2008
this is the latest version of the
specification that governs how internet
email behaves and it says at the top
that if it doesn't work straight away
you should wait at least 30 minutes
before you try again and that you should
try for four or five days before you
give up trying to send an email so try
it doesn't work yeah come back in half
an hour and you're sitting there going
at it and your boss is like I thought
you were fixing that production problem
and you're like no no boss azir is
sending me an email so I can sign in
it'll take four to five days I'm just
going to Goof Off and play a little bit
of halflife while it's coming through
now the good news is all of you who did
not get that email you can come and get
one of these I got some of these on the
stage at the end this is the sticker
that should have been an email you've
seen the meeting that could have been an
email well now we have sticker
equivalents of that so you can come and
grab one of those actually we got plenty
you can all come and grab one of those
at the end but we're going to talk about
this whole kind of how do we end up in
this situation where the spec says it
can take five days but we all assume
it's going to take like three or four
seconds for email to get through and how
do we as developers and Engineers how do
we build software that works reliably in
a world where those are the rules now my
background in this area um I started
building web apps I built my first web
page in about 1992 I'm an internet
dinosaur and uh in 2002 I built an
application this is back when the
internet had a connection wizard because
it wasn't switched on all the time you
had to plug your dialup modem in and uh
one of the clients that I worked with
when I came out of University was this
company Spotlight and uh Spotlight is a
job information service for professional
actors and I built them A system that
sent notices about auditions and plays
and movies that were looking for
and it did it by email in 2002 it
replaced fax machines this was a pretty
neat idea at the time now this was built
in classic ASP I had a little Loop that
would send each email and when it sent
one it would response. write dot dot dot
dot dot and then when it got to the end
it would redirect you to a page that
said it's all done it was very
rudimentary but it worked it had a kind
of immediacy to it and it was incredibly
successful now by the time I left
Spotlight I was there for about 15 years
so I built this 2002 I left in 2018 I
joined their team I moved up there I
built the team I built successive
versions of this software upgraded it
from classic ASP to net to um aspnet MVC
and microservices all this kind of stuff
by the time I left they were sending
about a quarter of a million emails a
day and this is not sending the same
email 250,000 times this is that many
jobs times that many parts in films and
stuff times that many person
personalizations for 50,000 paying
customers and it wasn't evenly
distributed either because there was
this interesting phenomenon in the way
that the Showbiz working day worked we
were based in London in the UK now in
London in Show Business nobody does any
work in the morning they stagger into
work with a stinking hangover they sit
and drink coffee until it's time to go
for lunch they go to lunch then they get
back to their desks about 2: p.m.
they're like H should probably do some
work today and so they start sending out
all the casting notices for all the
stuff they've got coming up at the same
time as everybody in New York and
Broadway and the New York television
scene they kind of finish their first
latte of the morning they're like right
let's get some stuff out there at the
same time as Los Angeles and Hollywood
finish their power breakfast and start
yelling at their assistants to get their
breakdowns out so we had this massive
volume of email going through the system
concentrated in about a three-hour chunk
every afternoon so we're sending about
50,000 emails an hour that's about 10
emails per second for three hours every
weekday afternoon for upwards of a
decade and when I left all this stuff
was still going on now you probably have
an idea in your head what do you think a
professional actor looks
like some of them look like this a very
few of them look like this these are the
successful ones the average professional
actor looks like this because they don't
have a job right now because being a
professional actor means you spend 11
months out of 12 chasing your next
audition and and hoping that you get the
part and so you sit at home and you
drink tea and you push Refresh on your
email every 15 seconds because you have
nothing better to do and if the emails
stop coming through you phone us and
you're like I haven't had any email for
20 minutes is everything all right and
of course the truthful answer is yes
everything's fine just nobody wants to
hire you go away but you can't say that
to your paying customers because you
love them and you want them to be happy
and keep giving you their money and so
we engineered a system like if you said
there's no email coming through we
needed to be able anyone on you know
help desk customer service in that
company well like what's your email
address yes bang click this click that
yes according to demon internet you went
over quter at 11:15 last night you have
too much email go and delete some so we
had to build that level of visibility
around all the reasons why email might
have stopped working in the night now
because I'm an idiot the whole time that
I'm doing this for money I'm also
running my own email server for fun I
ran a what's called a qmail box a q Q
mail is an open- Source mail relay that
runs on Linux and Unix and I ran a qmail
system which hosted all my email and
about a dozen of my friends for 15 years
ran all my own email on premise on an
old hulet Packard workstation I
eventually stopped doing that and you
will find out why over the course of
this talk and then the Third Kind of uh
point I guess in in favor of my
credibility as to why I can stand up
here and talk to all of you about how to
work with email is uh some of you got an
email recently that looked like this and
I know you did cuz if you didn't you
wouldn't have been able to get into the
building so all the people who didn't
get it they're outside we don't need to
worry about them but I built the system
that sends these emails I built the
ticket platform that NDC is using to run
run NDC Porto and when we were kind of
bootstrapping the system last year and
setting it up for London there were all
kinds of weird quirks with companies
where like the company employed another
company to run their email and that
company employed another company to do
their junk mail filtering and that
company decided that NDC conferences
were sending spam and we're like we're
not sending spam people have paid lots
of money this is a conference ticket
it's expensive um and so we had to go
through all the Motions what do you need
to do to get all of that as bulletproof
as you can possibly get it so that's
what the kind of experience that I'm
bringing to this talk now we're going to
start the beginning this is 1961 it's a
computer called the compatible time
sharing system now email is older than
networks the ctss didn't connect to any
other computers it was a massive like
Bank of drives the size of refrigerator
well tape drives the size of
refrigerators um in a a university in
California somewhere I think don't
correct me YouTube I think it was
California but you could look it up and
uh you could leave messages for the
other users on this computer so you
could send mail but you weren't actually
sending it because it didn't go anywhere
it just got stored on tape and when your
colleagues came in the next day and they
logged in they would see the messages
you left for them so this was like
leaving Post-its on a really expensive
refrigerator this was the first system
that allowed you to send messages to
other people like I said there was no
networks involved it was just one single
system now we're going to jump forward
about 8 years to
1969 because if the United States of
America was a television program 1969
would have been a season finale where
they pull out all the stops because
America did so much cool stuff in 1969
they walked on the moon that was pretty
awesome it was the year that the Boeing
747 flew for the first time it was the
year that the lock supersonic spy plane
the Sr 71 flew for the first time it was
the year of Woodstock kind of rounded
out so apparently it wasn't the Summer
of Love That was 1967 old people on the
internet have complained at me about
that one but Woodstock was 69 and so you
had this massive kind of engineering and
culture and counterculture and this a
huge sort of Celebration all this stuff
going on and it was the year that they
kind of invented the Internet because
this the ARA Network Advanced research
projects agency December 1969 now prior
to this point there were some computers
that talked to each other by just I
would my computer would dial your
computer and we'd exchange data but this
was the first thing when people talk
talk about connecting to the network
this the network it's the network this
was the thing they were talking about
and aranet started in 1969 and uh it had
four nodes and the big revolution of
aranet was any computer on that Network
could talk to any other computer on that
Network and as soon as this came along
people went well if the computers can
talk to each other maybe the human can
also use them to send messages to each
other now internet email is a
culmination of probably hundreds of
people contributing ideas and
specifications and code over Decades of
uh Decades of work it wasn't invented by
one person but one of I think the most
influential contributors to it was this
guy was Ray Tomlinson and he uh in the
early 70s was working on one of the
first systems for sending email over the
arpanet and Ray Tomlinson is the person
who decided to use app
in email addresses now early email
addresses look like this there's no or
net or PT ored on it's just Alice MIT
multic because it's your user at your
host name we didn't have things like yet
because we didn't need them because in
1972 if you were connected to the arper
net you wanted to put a new machine on
you'd get it out of the box you'd plug
it in you'd switch it on and then you
talk to Jake Elizabeth finer uh
apparently when she was a kid uh
something about her little sister called
her baby jake instead of baby Jane and
the name stuck and she was known as Jake
for her entire life and uh she ran the
network information center at Stanford
University or Stanford Research
Institute from 1972 to 1988 and Jake and
her team maintained the hosts file we've
all got hosts files there's one on your
phone there's one on your laptop and
sometimes if you're having a really bad
day you need to edit it but the host
file used to be a file it was a text
file that would get copied Around the
Net on paper tape or using FTP and these
kinds of things and it was a list of
every computer on the network along with
all the contact details of the person
who looked after it street address their
real name their telephone number and
their email address now when
technological innovation comes around
there are kind of two sorts of people in
the world there are the people who look
at it and go that would be really cool
and useful and it's going to make my
life easy and there are people who look
at it and go that would be really cool
and useful and I bet I can use it to get
rich
this is Gary Turk now Gary Turk is one
of those people who's this kind of
really significant figure in the history
of computing but uh kind of the thing he
did he was young enough when he did it
that if you type his name into Google
the top match is his LinkedIn CU he's
still out there and he's still working
on stuff and uh Gary was the inventor he
says in his profile he's the father of e
marketing now Gary worked for a company
called deck the digital Equipment
Corporation 19 19 78 and they've just
launched this thing this is the deck
system 20 it's one of the first
computers that had arpanet protocols
built into it and being a sales engineer
at deck he kind of figured well we
should let people know people on the
aranet are going to want to know about
our computer that does opet stuff and uh
deck had a big thing on the US East
Coast they had a lot of offices they
were very well known in New York and
Boston but the West Coast not so much
and so he paid somebody to go through
the hosts file and type in all the email
address of everybody on the internet on
the west coast you know let's not be be
silly here and uh he sent an email to
all of them and uh the email looked like
this now about a third of the way down
he overflowed the address buffer that
email supported and so all the people
who received this got an email that
started with 200 lines of other people's
email addresses and then right at the
end it had this little bit going we
invite you to come and see the deck
system 2020 now this is generally
regarded as the first first spam ever
sent May 1978 that's when spam started
now the aranet the advanced research
projects agency was funded by the United
States Department of Defense has any of
you ever got in trouble at work and like
your boss maybe shouted at you a little
bit and I have you ever gotten enough
trouble that uh the police shouted at
your boss have you ever screwed up so
badly that the United States Air Force
yelled at the person who owns your
company
because that's what happened to Gary
Turk is Major Raymond chhor from the
United States Air Force got in touch
with his boss at deck and said you do
not do this on a defense network do
you hear me this is not for marketing
now there's a tiny window there where
maybe we could have fixed some of this
stuff but the problem was that all the
people who used email in the
1970s they were hippies and Libertarians
and they went well obviously we can
trust people to behave so so they just
went yeah pinky promise we won't send
junk email ever again it's fine we're
very sorry and we won't do it anymore
now our timeline from this point forward
you know they have these kind of
demographics like there was the Baby
Boomers and then there was Generation X
and then there were the Millennials and
then there's Generation Z and then
there's generation Alpha and there's
this little weird Gap in the middle of
people who were not quite sure what
those people are you know what do we
call them when we do these these
population demographic studies now the
definition that I subscribe to is that
Generation X is the people who were born
before Star Wars if you were born before
Star Wars came out you are Generation X
and if you were born after Return of the
Jedi you are a millennial Star Wars
1977 Return of the Jedi 1983 the people
in the middle we are the millennial
Falcons we are the
microgeneration and the greatest
Millennial Falcon of them all is the
internet as we know it because when Star
Wars came out in
1977 the aranet used the NCP network
communication protocol tcpip didn't
exist yet everything was done using the
hosts file junk mail had not been
invented yet this had never happened
skip six years forward by the time
Return of the Jedi comes out the
internet is called the internet tcpip is
a published standard and most people
have started embracing it on their
systems January 1st 1983 is when tcpip
rolled out DNS is becoming widespread
the standards are published it's being
adopted it's replacing host files and as
we've just seen junk mail has been very
much invented and one of the other
things that was invented in that window
was SMTP simple maale transfer protocol
it was invented by this guy John poell
and the thing about SMTP it's a propri
it's a a protocol that was documented in
1982 it was incredibly successful and
the problem with successful technology
is once you got a lot of people using
your stuff you kind of get stuck with it
like we could build I'm sure most of us
in this room we could build an amazing
email system right now that solved all
the technological problems of SMTP and
internet mail but it would be useless
because we'd have to persuade everyone
else to use it and they're not going to
because they don't want our system
because their system works with your
system and your system talks to your
system and your system talks to Yahoo
and Amazon and Microsoft and the people
who you pay your bills to and all this
kind of stuff so SMTP kind of got we got
stuck with it the thing that came out in
1982 was so successful that today in
2023 41 years later we still have email
systems that can communicate with that
in terms of reverse compatibility
imagine you went out you bought an M2
silicon MacBook and it came with a tape
drive so that you could load your
PowerPoint slides off a data cassette
that's the kind of backwards
compatibility that we're talking about
here now one of the things that was
published in 1982 was the format of an
email address what is and is not valid
uh how many of you folks out there have
written code to validate an email
address did you use a regular
expression yeah we we've all been there
right did it
work sometimes
now let's take a look at some sample
data so let's say we're going to bring
in the Avengers here because this sounds
like a job for The Avengers right and uh
we got the The Avengers email addresses
here that I found in one of Troy Hunt's
data breaches so Iron Man is is iron.man
avengers. comom valid email address yeah
yeah yeah we think does anyone think
it's not I mean you're not going to
admit it in front of this crowd but how
about spider hen man avengers. comom we
good with
that how about tala with the apostrophe
in it I see some shaking heads how about
rocket plus Gro avengers. comom yeah I
see nodding
what about Bruce thehulk Banner at
avengers.
comom I how about Vision so Vision
doesn't care about all of that human
readable DNS crap vision is an IPv6
address literal expressed in
hexadecimal I have disturbing news for
you friends these are all valid every
single one of these is a valid email
address according to the specifications
that govern internet email so maybe
validity is not really the right
question maybe we shouldn't be asking is
the email address valid or not because
really that's not going to get us very
far now an email address consists of two
parts there is a domain part and this
controls where is this email going and
there is a local part and that controls
what happens when it gets there so the
way that email kind of works is uh you
can speak email using telnet from a a
command prompt on Windows I can go onto
my laptop I can open a C drive I can
type in NS look up and it'll go hey
here's your DNS server and I'm like all
right uh set type equals MX I want to
look for MX male exchange records and I
want to see what are the mail exchanger
records for funwith doil that's a domain
that I set up for the purpose of this
talk and it's going to come back okay
here you go mail exchanger SMTP 1 SMTP 2
there is a number in there called
preference some people call that
priority now priority is a stupid name
for it because when we talk which number
is higher 10 or 20 20 is higher than 10
right can we at least agree on that but
a server with priority 10 is a higher
priority than a server with priority 20
so we call it preference if anyone calls
it Priority they are wrong and they are
probably confused so that says look try
this one and if you can't get to that
one you try this one and if you can't
get to either of them go away for half
an hour and keep trying for four or five
days we've already seen that part right
now I can then tell net into that mail
relay and I can say says hello nice to
see you and and I can say hello I'm
Dylan bt.net and it says okay I'm SMTP
fun with email I say I have mail from
Dylan Dillan bt.net and it says okay and
I say recipient to hello at funwith
email and this point is where the server
on the other side decides am I going to
let you get away with this or not and uh
as we've seen validity based on
specifications isn't going to get us
very far I wanted to do some research so
I went on Google and I looked up what
are the best email providers for doing
stupid experiments and then I went no no
no scrap that scrap that scrap that
let's a best business email posting what
are the companies out there that you
should trust to run your mail if you're
doing something important with email and
I found some wonderful resources I found
uh this article on PC Magazine the best
hosted email providers in 2020 are
Salesforce uh GoDaddy which is best for
Microsoft Office 360 users uh Zoho Mail
is good for Zoho loyalists we could
probably have figured that out and
apparently the best email system for
Microsoft organ organizations is
teams now in case you're not familiar
with the landscape of Corporate email
this is like you went onto car magazine
and you said what are the best economy
family cars for 2020 and it went was the
Hyundai Tucson and there's bicycles and
there's frania and there's
penguin and you're like only one of yeah
but I also found some articles written
by serious journalists who are good at
their jobs which recommended all kinds
of things and I kind of looked at a
bunch of the and I narrowed it down to a
choice of five now disclaimer here I am
going to show you a bunch of stuff that
I did with corporate email providers
these are serious companies out there
that every single one of them is a
really good Rock Solid product the
sensible things that normal people do
all worked brilliantly on every one of
these platforms this what I'm doing is
the equivalent of Let's test a bunch of
cars we're going to fill the car with
gravel we're going to set it on fire we
going to drive it across a bridge and
we're going to does it blow up before it
sinks it's destruction testing I don't
want anyone going away from this talk
and going oh well we shouldn't use Zoho
Mail because in Dylan's talk he couldn't
do that is not what this is about we
clear so what I did is I took Office 365
Google workspace the people who run
Gmail um Zoho Mail proton mail and fast
mail now I didn't tell any of them I was
doing this I just went on and set up
accounts as a regular ordinary paying
customer and then I registered
subdomains for every single one of those
providers so I can set up all the DNS
and everything to root email to all of
those different providers then I went on
to all of them I was like right what
mail boxes will these things let me
create so tchala with the little
apostrophe in the email address there
can I create tchala at funwith email
Google says yes absolutely fine office
says yes Zoho Mail put into Chala I
click add yep it kind of looks like it's
worked but then when I click update I
get error sending response expected
thing at line 40 so they're backend
supports it but I'm guessing the people
who wrote their front end weren't
expecting an email address with a quote
in it and it's breaking the Json big
deal we're going to give that a frowny
face proton mail to Chala save address
nope not allowed you can't have that
okay so no for that one and fast mail to
Chala it says please check this all
right let's try rocket plus Groot now
this is where we get into something
interesting let's we into the difference
between addresses and mailboxes and
delivery and rooting because I can go
onto Gmail and I can put in rocket plus
gr it says email cannot contain special
characters but you can absolutely send
mail with a plus in it to a Gmail hosted
account because most of us have probably
done it now it turns out there is a
thing called email address sub
addressing and uh this is the standard
that kind of recommend this is not
supported by everybody universally but
what it says is that you can put like
address plus something and everything
before the plus that's the domain
mailbox and everything after after the
plus we'll sort that out later so this
should be deliverable and what I
discovered is that over the over time
this has been embraced every Gmail
supported this since 2008 is the
earliest thing I could find um fast mail
has supported it proton mail supports it
Zoho male supports it and uh as of May
2022 Microsoft supports sub addressing
as well so as of now you can't use Plus
in mailboxes but you can use it to send
mail on all of these so when we say plus
group yes it's a valid email address but
no it's not a valid mailbox
name now something just interesting I
want to flag out here plus addressing
means that all of these Iron Man plus
Javis Iron Man plus Thor Iron Man plus
Nick plus Fury they will all end up
going into the same mailbox but there's
something else that Google do which is
interesting which is that Gmail
addresses will ignore dots so uh Iron
Man iron.man i. r.o ion. man plus Javis
ion. man plus n man all of these also go
to Iron Man gmail.com now uh if any of
you knows a town in Australia called
cundra in camra there is a moods IGA
which is like a grocery and liquor store
there is a Dylan Bey who works there and
I know that cuz I get his pce lips
because he thinks that his email address
is Dylan BT gmail.com and it's not
that's mine and I would email him to
tell him but it just comes back to me
like a boomerang so if anyone's in the
neighborhood of camra anytime soon go to
the moods IG ask for and be just give
him a little slap and ask him how he
thinks the internet possibly works when
some guy in London is getting all of his
shifts and all of his pce lips and
that's just because of this dot thing
Google thinks they're the same address
so let's try Bruce Banner in quotes
because we can put spaces in the local
part if we quote it you can't do this on
anything nowhere will let you create a
mailbox which has a space in the mailbox
address name this is a complete
non-starter here but let's try a couple
more interesting edge cases what about
uh just quote single quote on its own as
a mailbox name Google says yeah that's
fine Outlook says yeah that's fine Zoho
male says invalid username all right
fair enough proton mail says no we can't
do that we're already seen that fast
mail says please check this all right
that one's not going to work what about
single
hyphen Google says email cannot be a
single hyphen well what about double
hyphen yeah it worked so you can't be
minus at but you can't be minus minus at
that's fine um Outlook says yeah you can
be hyphen at whatever you want um Zoho
proton fast mail says this name is
already taken now it's
not but okay we can't create it I'm
going to give that a frowny face um so
this is a complete set of aliases that I
was able to set up the last one is just
underscore at that works on Google it
works on Office 365 Zoho
mailor
s101 what is s 101 okay let's open the
Chrome Network inspector we'll take a
look the response that comes back looks
like this it's a Json error message that
says 200
okay good game good game I'm going to
put that as a cross and finally fast
mailor at great
choice so there we go that's what this
whole idea of validity actually looks
like is it depends where you're getting
your email from and it depends what kind
of addresses you're trying to implement
and it depends how that company is
interpreting the specification now the
other thing that I set up is I set up
what's called a catchall address and a
catchall just says look any mail that
comes to this domain it's fine I don't
care who it's addressed to I'll take it
and then we'll figure out later because
I was thinking maybe with a Catal
address I could try out some of these
weird esoteric edge cases so I went on
to Gmail and I tried to send mail to
quote Bruce Banner with a space in the
middle and it just said no you can't you
can't send mail to that and I tried it
on proton and it said you can't do that
either so I started thinking now we saw
a moment
ago just check email address validity so
this is the actual rule about whether an
email address is valid or not is does it
contain at least one at sign if it
doesn't it's not valid if it does
contain at least one at sign it depends
there you go that that is official email
validation can an email address be case
sensitive it can if you're
evil the bit on the right the domain
part that's d s and DNS is case
insensitive by Design uppercase
lowercase the internet doesn't care the
bid on the left absolutely can be case
sensitive now when SMTP rolled out in
the early 80s a lot of places that
implemented it were implementing it on
top of a Unix Mail system that already
existed and on Unix systems they have a
case sensitive file system which means
your mailbox is the same as your home
directory which is the same as your
username and your home directory is on a
case sensitive hard drive and so it's
case sensitive and so Alice with a
little a and Alice with a big a could be
different users on a Unix machine you
know if you were evil if you think this
is a good idea we have to have a talk
but there's nothing technically stopping
you doing it now generally this isn't a
problem however there are certain
organizations hello Airlines I'm looking
at you that when you put your email
address in they flip it into uppercase
immediately probably because they're
still running cobal somewhere in the
background and so if your software is
converting users email addresses from
lower case to uppercase it is just
possible that somebody out there who is
technically correct is no longer going
to be able to get email from you because
they have implemented the specification
in a way that you are ignoring so yeah
you can have case sensitive email you
probably shouldn't and if you do that's
your problem but technically you're not
breaking any rules let's go back to our
little transcript here now I've T ited
and I've said mail from I've have
recipient to and it's going to say okay
that's cool I know who that is I'm going
to send mail for that and this point I'm
going to say here's some data and I'm
going to say Hello dot on its own ends
the email cued as there's a message I do
boom done and I can go and I can open my
fun with email and there is that message
and it says hello and there's a message
ID there's nothing on the envelope I
don't know where it came from I don't
know where it's going to none of that
stuff is included but it got delivered
it got to where we were going now at
this point I'm thinking hang on if I can
send email by injecting stuff directly
onto Port 25 Maybe I can try that to
send email with spaces in it so I did an
NS lookup for protonmail pm. funwith and
it said mail
protonmail.ch and I T neted into them
and I said hello fun with email here
I've got mail from me and I'd like to
send it to fun with email and it goes no
protocol
error can't do that okay so scratch
proton mail let's try another one let's
try Zoho so Zoho there's their mail
exchanger we tell n into it there's that
we say hello we say mail from this we
say recipient to it says relaying dis
aab now technically I'm not relaying
technically I'm delivering but that's
tripped some bit of their validation
that's looking at the wrong thing okay
not going to work let's try Google yep
tell it into Google Port 25 hello mail
from recipient
to the recipient address is not a valid
RFC 5321 now that's lies because it is
because I've read the spec and that is
totally valid it's just that Google is
saying it isn't now I don't know who's
right here Google or the standard
because Google's got a lot more money
than the standard
right let's try it with Microsoft so I
uh got the the outlook.com mail relay I
Ted into that now the interesting thing
I found is that every single server that
I tried this from I got the same error
saying service unavailable this was the
uh the alfandega Wi-Fi this morning
saying you can't send it through that
every Network that I tried I could not
relay email through outlook.com it just
wouldn't let me I couldn't find one
anywhere but I did a version of this
talk in Oslo earlier this year and I got
an email afterwards from Thomas
eisenberger saying hey I have a machine
here that hasn't been blacklisted by
Microsoft so I thought I'd give it a try
and so Thomas sent me a transcript of
connecting to Ms fun with email and
sending that through and there's fun
with email and uh there's the email
address I'd call it a success and it
queued the mail for delivery and just as
it's looking really
promising we get a non- delivery report
cuz micros oh we but then afterwards we
decided that we didn't want that anymore
so sad face for Microsoft so we got one
left to try we got fast
mail um so I'm going to tell it into
them and I'm going to go hello fun
withth email mail from this recipient to
funwith email fm. funwith
email now this is looking
promising this was sent to an email
address with spaces in it queued for
delivery did it work there it is it
worked so FastMail you can actually send
email with spaces in the email address
and it goes oh yeah that's fine we can
cope with that um and you notice it's
taken all the quotes off so now you get
this thing which you're looking at and
you know I would love to show this to
help desks and go can you tell me what
happened with this email here because
they'd be like we don't know and we
don't want to be help desk anymore
now all of the stuff we've been doing
there this is kind of Direct Delivery
I'm finding the place the email has to
go and I'm talting into it and I'm
formatting the message by hand that's
not really how messaging works in real
life if we want to send a message to uh
his Excellency uh Lazarus chaera who's
the Prime Minister of Malawi um we are
not going to go to Malawi and go to the
top of the hill and knock on the door of
the presidential Palace one it's a long
way that's an expensive trip just to
send one letter two he might be out and
then we'd be like ah we come all this
way for nothing no if we want to send a
letter like that we put a stamp on it
and we stick it in a mailbox and we
trust the global delivery infrastructure
to take care of that thing for us now
this works
in reality because physical mail has
certain built-in constraints one of them
is it costs money even you got the cost
of the postage you got to buy a postage
stamp you got to address the thing you
got to physically carry it to the m you
got to print it have you seen how much
printer ink costs these days if you were
running some kind of a scam where you
wanted to contact a million people and
if any one of them bought your product
you'd make a profit on the deal that
would have to be an unbelievably
profitable product because you are going
to be in the hole for a couple of
hundreds of thousand thousands of Euros
just from the costs of sending that many
messages so physical mail works because
it has fundamental built-in constraints
internet email does not have fundamental
built-in constraints and so if we go and
take a look at what's in my mailbox
today Alisa Williams hello dear I'm
looking for a special friendship and
Martin Smith's web design pric is number
one on Google and Mark is sending me
steel products manufacturers and the the
president is sending me crossborder
international monetary fund uh Kelly
McGoldrick I just want to tell you how
I'm feeling I've got Joe Dillan your
subscription has been
confirmed this is crap this is a massive
Relentless fire hose of crap now we have
decided that this is called spam the
internet says that junk mail's called
spam because of a Monty Python sketch
about a bunch of Vikings singing a song
in a cafe I have never really understood
why the Vikings in the cafe but it just
stuck spam became this term for noise
that drowns out the signal in the
communication medium that you're looking
at and the reason spam is such a problem
is that email was invented by hippies
and hippies are like oh peace and love
man and everything's fine and for most
of the history of the first part of the
internet this just kind of worked
because everyone was nice because you
know the evil people probably weren't
smart enough to get online and even if
they did there was only so much damage
they could do but then the '90s comes
around and what happened in the '90s was
revolutionary because um we had
this and suddenly an entire generation
of people who had never had access to
any networks before started getting the
web and they started getting email and
it wasn't just that we were rolling out
connections and dial up and Broadband
all these kind of things is that we were
giving people a set of communication
paradigms that they had no frame of
reference for and so some point in the
'90s someone opens their email and
they've got a photograph of their
grandchild who was born in Australia an
hour ago now this is too good to be true
you cannot send a color photograph from
Australia to the United States in an
hour but suddenly there it is and there
they are and look they're so cute this
is just amazing it's too good to be true
but there it is right before your eyes
and then the email below that one is
Bill Gates saying that he's partnered
with Disneyland and everyone who
forwards this email is going to get a
million dollars well the first one was
true why wouldn't the second one be true
as well and so scams and spam we had no
filter for knowing what was real and
what was fake and what was a scam and
what wasn't now the good news is that
this junky mail problem was completely
solved by uh the um controlling the
assault of non-solicited pornography and
Marketing Act 2003 which was the
American government going we will make a
law and that will stop spam forever and
that's why none of us has had any junk
mail for the last 20 years turns out
they missed two things one nobody gives
a crap and two most people people aren't
in America and really couldn't give a
crap and actually it is ridiculously
easy to comply with all the conditions
of the can spam act by going we are
going to send unsolicited email but
here's our street address and you can
unsubscribe here and good luck trying to
prosecute us this accomplished nothing
the second approach to dealing with
unsolicited commercial email is client
side filtering now most of us use this I
use this Gmail has this Outlook has this
I'm not going to talk about that in this
talk because it's it's not really any
kind of Technology standard as a
developer that is interesting to you
trying to deliver mail to your customers
they can set up their filters however
they like and there's nothing you can do
about it and so we are just going to
step away from that problem if you want
to filter your email you go for it your
mail your filters your rules we are not
interested and so that leaves us with a
third option which is can we stop the
bad people getting on the internet in
the first place cuz it turns out what we
really needed from the hippies was we
needed Peace Love and
authentication peace and love is all
very well but we kind of like to know
where it's coming from now one of the
big steps towards this was uh SMTP 1982
version no security no usernames no
passwords no negotiation just hey I have
mail for you and the other system goes
yay give me all the mail it's fine so we
created a new version and we didn't call
it the complex mail transfer protocol
because that would have confused people
we called it extended
simple because of course we we did now
uh extended simple is uh does anyone
remember this movie anyone know this or
am I sure yeah yeah I got some nodding
heads uh extended SMTP is based on the
film Labyrinth because there's the scene
where Sarah gets in The Labyrinth and
she meets the worm and uh she says to
the worm did you say hello and the worm
says no I said hello but that's close
enough because if you want to start an
extended SMTP conversation with a remote
server you tnet into their mail server
and you don't say hello you say hello
and a server on the other end goes oh
cool you speak extended SMTP all right
here's the menu this is all the stuff I
can do I support authentication I can do
plane I can do login I can do cram with
an md5 checkm I can do start TLS if you
want to move this onto a secure Channel
I can do enhanced status codes and we
send back okay cool let's start TLS
let's get this on a secure Channel it
says okay let's start again I send L it
says cool I send hey Authentication and
I send a username and password base 64
encoded I send that over it goes hey
cool we know who you are this is great
now we can have a civilized grown-up
conversation now this works brilliantly
for sending mail via my relay so I got
my ISP I want to send some mail I can
talk to them and go look it's definitely
me could you please send this to Lazarus
triera send this to Microsoft send us
wherever it's going in the other
direction it doesn't work so well
because one of the reasons EMA is such a
wonderful and Powerful protocol is the
ability to I can receive mail from
anyone on the planet we've never met we
don't have any kind of agreement I don't
know who they are but like uh Thomas who
sent me the transcript of the Microsoft
I'd never met the guy before he saw my
talk on YouTube and he emailed me and I
got it and that's awesome and that's
amazing but there is no system we've
come up with with knows that Thomas is a
good guy who's trying to help and this
person here is a weird scammer who's
trying to steal my money now one of the
most interesting people in the history
of kind of electronic freedom and stuff
is this guy John Gilmore and uh John is
noted for a quote he had he said the net
interprets censorship as damage and
Roots around it his theory is that if
you try to restrict the flow of
information on a resilient Network
artificially the protocols are just
going to go well that server isn't
working and the protocols don't care
that there's a firewall or there's
authentication the protocols just go
well that one doesn't work so we'll go
this way we'll find another way around
it now John is one of those people who I
agree with like 90 I agree with 95% of
what he says and then the last 5% I'm
like did you really have to go there
because John runs an open SMTP relay
which he refuses to switch off and he is
like you know a flag waving libertarian
he's like everyone in the world has the
right to send anonymous unencrypted
email it's a fundamental part of the
network um this is his SMTP relay hop.
to.com there is not an ISP or an access
point in the world that will let you
talk talk to this it's out there and if
you can get to it you can use it to
relay mail but one most things won't let
you talk to it in the first place and
two anything coming from to.com most
internet providers are like we are not
touching this we this is a hive of scum
and villainy we're not letting any of
that mail in there um and I really
wanted to use hop. to.com in the live
demo at the start of this talk but you
try and send mail from Azure to that and
they go no please don't do that anymore
or we're going to switch off all your
azure so we need to deal with this
problem when a piece of mail arrives at
our mailbox we don't want to restrict
people's ability to connect but then
when it gets there we want something
that will allow us to go is this valid
is this legitimate are we interested in
taking delivery of this piece of
information now one approach that has
been used for this is the idea of
real-time databases of all the services
that send spam now on one of my my tools
we'll see in a second I got this
breakdown this is all the different
datab dates and these basically say look
we'll keep a list of all the bad people
and if you get a piece of email you can
look in our database and see if it's
from the bad people and if it is you can
drop it the problem with this approach
is that to become one of the bad people
all you need to do is upset one person
one time for one minute and they can put
you on the bad people list and then
you're like H I can't send email anymore
someone's put me on the bad people list
and then you need to remove yourself
which means you need to find out which
list you've made it on to you need to go
onto their website you need to go this
is definitely me this is my address you
need to wait 48 hours you can only do
this once a week this is why I stopped
running my own mail server because even
though I was doing everything right and
had all the right DNS records and nobody
else had access I wasn't running an open
relay about once a month I'd end up on
one of these lists because somebody on
an adjacent IP address was sending junk
and so they'd be like we we'll block the
whole the whole IP address block and
just the time of constantly having
having to prove my innocence as a Neen
in good standing got overwhelming I got
completely fed up with it I decided I
was going to get somebody else to do
that all that stuff for me which is kind
of a shame because it was fun now if you
go on to uh the Google DNS toolbox or
the Google dig toolbox here we're going
to take a look at fun with email now
that currently has no records on a
because it's not a website but if we
bounce across to the text records for
fun with email you can see in here we
got this record here V SPF IP for
include now this is how we are using DNS
to authenticate mail what we're doing is
we are saying look this domain
authorizes certain people on the
internet to send mail on its behalf and
nobody else is allowed to do that now
the format of these records here V equal
spf1 SPF is the sender protection
framework and what I've said here is
look IP for this IP address is allowed
to send mail for fun with email this set
of addresses so SMTP is one of the
providers that I um used to send the
stuff at the start of the talk they're
good messaging engine.com they're good
and anybody else the little squiggle
here means this is a soft delete now the
plus is a pass that's the default and
normally can be skipped neutral means
don't care why would you have a rule
that says you don't care you use it for
Diagnostics and troubleshooting because
you can look in the logs and see that
you didn't care and if you didn't care
about the right things it's probably
safe to switch them on and a soft fail
is deliver it but don't tag it and you
can have hard fail you can publish a
rule to the whole world that says any
email that claims it came from funwith
email if it didn't come from one of
these relays or one of these servers you
can just delete it and not tell anyone
that it got deleted now the plus is the
default so you'll normally see that get
left out so we've got this whole
delivery authentication mechanism here
and all the stuff we talked about so far
is what's on the outside of the envelope
this is how does the thing get there in
the first place let's talk about what's
actually inside the thing here so we're
going to pretend uh that it's um it's
back in 1982 I got my pdp1 up here and
uh I want to send an email to uh say
Alice gmail.com I can send from to
subject hello this is the whole message
body now this stuff here this is not
rooting information this is for the
human recipient on the other end now
this stuff has to be seven bit asky
because it has to be backwards
compatible with a standard from 1982 so
all the stuff you put in your email
headers all the stuff you put in the
body of your email text email brilliant
as long as everything you have to say
can be represented as a seven bit asky
text message you're absolutely fine we
send this this comes through the other
end this is a message about how email is
fun have a lovely day now but what what
if we want to send more what if we want
to send accented characters what if we
want to send PDFs what if we want to
send video files and animated Gifts of
Rick Ashley and other important
information we're going to use the mime
multi-purpose internet mail extensions
now Mime is one of those things you've
all seen it you've probably only really
seen it when it goes wrong because when
it works it's invisible mime is really
really clever what mime exists to be
able to do is we need to be able to take
any arbitrary set of data and turn it
into seven bit asky and then rehydrated
at the other end so we're going to say
hey we got email H it's from fun with
email it's to Dylan Bey here's the
subject there's the date mime version
1.0 now when they created mime they
absolutely intended that there was going
to be 1.1 1.2 2.0 3.0 uh turns out that
some stuff got screwed up in the initial
implementation and so that 1.0 is
actually a floating Point Boolean if
it's 1.0 that's true and anything else
means it's not M and nobody ever figured
out how to make 1.1 or 2.0 work so there
we go my version 1.0 yes and then this
content type multi-art mixed boundary
equals now this little string in pink
here that can be anything as long as it
does doesn't occur in the body of your
mail message cuz what we're doing is
we're using that as a delimiter and then
we're going to say this is a multi-part
message in MIM format that opens a
container then we're going to put in a
boundary that opens another section
another container then inside this one
we're going to put more containers
inside the outer container so we're
going to say hey we're having fun with
email this is our text body we have
another delimiter we're having fun with
email this is our HTML body we're going
to close that one out we're going to
close that one out we're going to put in
another container here and we're going
to attach something we're going to
encode a a PNG image in sbit asky and we
are going to send that base 64 encoded
we get this big chunk of noise and then
at the other end this thing is going to
get reconstituted and rehydrated and
turned back into attachments and that's
how email works the stuff flowing
between my server and your server is s
bit asky same as it's been since 1982
and maybe one day we'll fix that or
maybe we won't
now when it comes to building building
software that gets this stuff right like
the fun with email demo that I built at
the beginning there's a whole bunch of
stuff that as developers you have to
worry about because the email you're
sending you have no idea what kind of
device it's going to get read on this
you have no control over this
environment it could be div mobile
phones could be tablets could be
widescreen TVs could be screen readers
could be any number of things somebody
could be using voice over to read their
email out to them while they're driving
so there's a bunch of things that as
developers we can do to make our lives
easier
one of them if we are sending Rich
formatted email don't write that by hand
there are two tools out there one is the
maale jet markup language which has a
logo the other one is called foundation
for email they don't have a logo they
have a cuttlefish but all right it works
for them and what these things do this
is an example of some mjml markup so it
looks like HTML but it's kind of
specialist HTML so this is nice this is
legible we got a head with a preview and
a body and a section column image yep
okay that's nice then when we run this
through the mailjet compiler it turns it
into this because this is what the email
looks HTML looks like that works with
email clients it's tables inside tables
inside tables inside tables all the way
down and if you're running Microsoft
Outlook you get another two tables for
free because that's the only way to do
layout because the things that render
HTM HTML email they differ so
dramatically in what they will and won't
do um I saw a talk a while ago someone
explained to me that Yahoo strips the
head of any HTML email message but it
only strips the first head so if you
send a HTML document with two heads
it'll only remove the first one and the
second one will survive and this is the
kind of thing people have figured out to
try and get HTML email to be delivered
reliably now these templating languages
are completely static they have no
notion of Loops or data injection or
templating so all of the the stuff the
things you got at the start of the talk
today and your tickets to NDC PTO they
were done by compiling mailjet into
Razer and then compiling Razer into HTML
as a kind of two-step deployment process
if you want to see how that works the
code for the demo is up on GitHub you
can go and take a look at it and so
you've got the email working and it
works on your machine email is the worst
thing in the world to use works on my
machine as any kind of validation you
want to give yourself a couple of extra
end points one if you are building any
kind of web-based system that sends
email you want to put an endo in there
that you can go into and you can so this
is the the live NDC dashboard I can
click on one of the customer emails and
I can see what it looks like now the
reason why that's useful as an
administrator is you can see what got
sent to somebody the reason it's useful
as a developer is I can refresh this
page if the email doesn't look right
reload reload reload hot reload I don't
even have to press controlr so I can get
the formatting and the layout just right
by refreshing a browser instead of
having to send a test message wait 5
seconds for it to come through refresh
my mailbox open it still doesn't look
Right Round We Go Again Round We Go
Again Round We Go Again the second thing
that I absolutely rely on when building
HTML email is a tool called paper cut
and paper cut is a Windows application
that sits in your system tray and gives
you a local SMTP server so I can send
mail to Local Host on Port 25 so I can
configure that in my application and
then every one of those that comes
through I can see the message I can see
the headers I can see the body I can
literally pull that message apart and
make sense of every single piece of it I
can see the raw message formatting and
this is another really fast feedback
loop level three is mail trap mail trap
is a cloud service that you send mail to
them and they grab it and then they
expose it in their dashboard now what
mail trap gives you is it gives you all
the visibility you get out of something
like paper cut but also it checks your
message against all of the common spam
relays and stuff so I can go onto spam
analysis and I can see on here this
message scored 0.8 out of five on a spam
score and it'll give me a breakdown of
all the reasons why that might have
happened and you can see on here the
little number in Orange there this is
when I just set up this demo and it's
given me that score because the domain
was less than a month old so all these
factors come into account if you want to
get your email to be deliverable I can
look at the HTML check and it'll say you
got this thing here that's not going to
work if people are using Yahoo mail on
iPhones this kind of visibility on it so
you've got everything right you are a
diligent meticulous professional you
have tested your
on Gmail and iOS mail Android Outlook
Zoho proton fast mail a Yo and then you
get the angry message from the customer
going the email doesn't look right and
you're like I tested it on everything
can you send me a screenshot and they
send you a screenshot and you're like oh
crap dark mode now there are two things
that I absolutely believe about email
one you have the right to view your
messages however you like you can
consume them on any device in any font
in any language
dark mode email is an eldrich horror
from beyond the
stars because there is no way of getting
it right you find any one of your
friends who is a graphic designer ask
them to design you a brochure or a
leaflet or an album cover or a book
cover and then say to them afterwards oh
yeah it might be on a black background
or it might be on a white background we
don't know the customer is going to
choose later they are going to get upset
because you cannot design things if the
user can flip the color from black to
white and back again but this kind of in
a nutshell is the whole Paradox of email
you know if you do have to do this kind
of stuff you end up with compromises
like every image you use has to be black
on white but you also need a border so
that if it comes up white on black you
can at least still see what's going on
with it and we're playing catchup we are
constantly playing catchup as developers
because the thing about email is that
email is a moving Target o there we go
let's get the moving Target there there
we go there it is email is a moving
Target every time we think we got
everything locked
down somebody comes out with a new
standard somebody comes out with a new
device somebody comes out with a new
profile somebody comes out with
something that we did not anticipate the
email address that validated yesterday
we'll skip that the email address that
was valid yesterday might not be valid
today the mail that you sent this
morning maybe you can't resend it this
afternoon you don't control this stuff
other people control this stuff or maybe
nobody controls this stuff and that
fundamentally is what I think is the
most wonderful thing about internet
email is nobody can mess with it it is
the only system we've got if I want to
send you a message on WhatsApp and the
people who are in WhatsApp decide they
don't like me no more WhatsApp for me
I'm not allowed to get on it same with
signal same with Discord same with
Facebook same with Twitter same with all
of these platforms they are owned by
people who can control communication
between us and yes we've seen a bunch of
stuff in here about junk mail and mail
relay blocking and difficulties
injecting stuff but fundamentally if I
want to talk to you and both of us know
how to set up a server we can use email
to communicate and there is nothing that
anybody else out there can do to
interfere with that conversation and
frankly you know I think that is special
I think that is something wonderful I
think that is something genuinely
remarkable and my final slide in this
talk is not going to come up because it
just does not want to so I'm going to
end things there by saying O
what I have here this is fun look I wish
I could show you what's going on on this
screen here there we go that's the slide
we are going to end on so there we go
folks go out there send email use it
it's wonderful it's awesome don't try
and get rich off it because you are
absolutely going to fail capitalism stop
trying to mess with email it's one of
the last things we've got left leave it
alone let us use it and if your client
insists that email has to render
beautifully and precisely the same
across all devices find a new client
because life is too short for that thank
you very much
folks let's just have a little look at
our report here and see how many emails
we got through each of our providers oh
there we
go s grid did pretty well SMTP to go so
that the allocations on here are random
yeah that's nice anyway any questions
folks marvelous The Silence of
Enlightenment everyone come down the
front and grab some stickers and thank
you very
much